[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend wenn drei sich
streiten freuen sich am Ende alle diesen
Anschein will die Ampelkoalition
jedenfalls nach dem gefundenen
Kompromiss in Sachen Gebäude
Energiegesetz erwecken die wochenlang
Streitereien und Schuldzuweisungen
geschenkt jetzt sind ja alle voll des
Lob sowohl was das Miteinander als auch
den Kompromiss an sich anbelangt und in
diesem wurde nun vieles aufgeweicht das
Klimaschutzgesetz geschrumpft aber auch
ein grober Konstruktionsfehler
korrigiert denn nun müssen erst die
Kommunen liefern und dann erst müssen
Eigentümer und Co handeln aber ist das
Theater damit wirklich beendet
insbesondere für Robert Habeck Frank
Buchwald
wo der Hammer hängt hat Robert Habeck in
den letzten Wochen ja schon häufiger
erfahren der Vizekanzler heute in
Duisburg es geht um grünen Stahl für den
Grünen Minister kein Heimspiel
[Musik]
ja
warum
Habeck hat Mühe durchzudringen auch in
Berlin wo die Leitplanken zu seinem
heizungsgesetz kontrovers diskutiert
werden die Opposition bleibt jedenfalls
skeptisch
ich verstehe das dass in Deutschland
eine große Unruhe ist und eine Regierung
darf sowas seinem Land nicht ihrem Land
nicht zumuten sehr klar und deshalb kann
ich nur sagen die Wahrheit liegt im
Gesetzestext nachher und das jetzt
präzise gearbeitet wird mehr Zeit für
Pellets Öl und Gasheizungen Kritik
deshalb auch aus dem eigenen Lager die
Klimaziele sein so nicht zu erreichen
bemängelt Umweltverbände die kommunale
wärmeplanung muss beschleunigt werden
der Bund muss dafür die Kommunen
unterstützen das heißt dass die
staatliche Förderung auf tatsächlich
klimafreundliche Lösungen wie
Wärmepumpen und eben nicht Holzheizung
ausgerichtet wird Anreize für mehr
Fernwärme und klimafreundlichere
Heizungen finden zwar alle gut wie die
Kosten dafür verteilt werden bleibt
jedoch umstritten
es kann nicht sein dass dafür eine
zusätzliche Modernisierungsumlage
geschaffen wird und damit der Mieter das
bezahlen soll im Ergebnis das halten wir
für völlig falsch die zusätzliche
Motivation finanzieller Art muss durch
staatliche Fördergelder erfolgen morgen
beginnen in Berlin die Beratungen im
Bundestag vielleicht müssen dann auch
noch die Länder zustimmen einer der
Ministerpräsidenten jedoch bisher
durchaus kritisch lobt heute den
Kompromiss die Anpassung an die
kommunale Werbeplanung nicht das ist das
entscheidende gewesen wir haben in
Baden-Württemberg gegeben die Städte
schon verpflichtet seit drei Jahren die
müssen bis Ende des Jahres diese
Werbeplanung schon vorlegen wir waren
also die ersten genau das wird jetzt im
Gesetz auch festgeschrieben in Duisburg
hat Harbeck den Hammer doch noch in die
Hand bekommen und wollte ihn dann gleich
mitnehmen nach Berlin vielleicht für die
nächste Koalitionsrunde das dürfte er
zwar nicht aber er weiß ja jetzt wo
liegt immerhin
das Gebäude Energiegesetz wird ja gerne
heizungsgesetz genannt was im Grunde
eine unzutreffende Verkürzung ist dann
es geht ja um weit mehr als nur um
Heizung aber heizungsgesetz ist halt so
schön griffig und wirkt auch für alle
verständlich beim nächsten großen Wurf
der Ampel wird es mit Verkürzungen etwas
schwieriger denn es geht um nichts
Geringeres als um die erste nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie für Deutschland
diese umfasst im Grunde alle
Lebensbereiche von cybersicherheit über
Katastrophenschutz Energieversorgung
Wasserqualität Verteidigung bis hin zum
nationalen Ausbau von Reserven bei
beispielsweise Nahrung oder Medikamenten
wie wichtig diese erste nationale
Strategie ist sah man heute auch daran
wer sie vorgestellt hat Thomas Reichert
vier Minister und ein Kanzler nehmen an
diesem Vormittag Anlauf sie sind spät
dran die nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
wollten sie eigentlich schon im Februar
präsentieren aber es gab Streit zwischen
Kanzler und Außenministerin wer wie viel
zu sagen hat bei der Außenpolitik der
großen Strategie nun endlich haben sie
einen Weg gefunden und ein bisschen
hampeleinigkeit bei allen Veränderungen
bleibt es die zentrale Aufgabe des
Staates für die Sicherheit seiner
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zu sorgen ohne
Abstriche
denn ohne Sicherheit gibt es keine
Freiheit keine Stabilität und auch
keinen Wohlstand es ist das erste Mal
dass Deutschland so offen seine
Interessen und Ziele formuliert zum
Beispiel gegenüber Russland der laut
Strategie größten Bedrohung für Frieden
und Sicherheit im euro-atlantischen Raum
der Anteil der Ausgaben für Verteidigung
wird deshalb steigen auf im Schnitt zwei
Prozent der Wirtschaftsleistung
wir müssen jetzt aus der Zeit der
Friedensdividende wechseln in die Zeit
der freiheits- und friedensinvestitionen
das bedeutet dass sich die Proportion
des Bundeshaushalts sich in den
kommenden Jahren verändern wird noch ein
Kurswechsel Rüstungsgeschäfte sollen
helfen Staaten wie Indien an den Westen
zu binden und sie zu lösen aus der
Abhängigkeit von Russland nach unserer
Überzeugung sind natürlich
Rüstungsexporte angesichts der neuen
Weltlage auch ein Teil des strategischen
Instrumenten
strategische Partnerschaften reden muss
es auch um diese Fragen gehen also auch
um eine neue Balance zu China heißt es
das Land seit partnerwettbewerber und
systemische Rivale Deutschlands
Abhängigkeit von Lieferungen aus oder
nach China soll vermindert werden mehr
dazu aber oder wie Deutschland mit
Pekings Macht streben umgeht wird es
erst nach der Sommerpause geben in einer
eigenen China Strategie in Berlin die
Union nur gut zwei Stunden um in den
Papier genauso viel zu finden nichts
Gutes das was wir jetzt hier vorliegen
haben als nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
ist inhaltlich blutleer strategisch
irrelevant operativ folgenlos und
außenpolitisch unabgestimmt und die
Linke kritisiert die Regierung setze die
falschen Prioritäten wir wollen nicht
dass immer mehr Milliarden in Aufrüstung
fließen sondern wir wollen dass die
Herausforderungen in dieser Welt sei es
die schreiende soziale Ungerechtigkeit
der Klimawandel oder die Pandemien dass
diese bewältigt werden die Strategie sei
ein Schritt hin zur Stärkung der
nationalen Sicherheit sagen Minister und
Kanzler heute es ist nach all dem Ringen
mindestens so sehr ein Schritt zur
Sicherung der Koalition
wie im Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart hat
Deutschland nun eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie bei der es nicht
nur um Verteidigung geht sondern um ein
integriertes Sicherheitskonzept für
innen wie außen federführend dafür ist
das Auswärtige Amt bzw die
Außenministerin und damit einen schönen
guten Abend nach Berlin Annalena
baerbock schönen guten Abend wo was oder
wer ist in ihren Augen die größte Gefahr
für Deutschland
die größte Gefahr für unseren Frieden
und unsere Freiheit in Europa ist
traurigerweise seit dem 24 februar im
vergangenen Jahr diese russische
Regierung das russische Regime und daher
haben wir auch im Rahmen unserer
nationalen Sicherheitsstrategie Dinge
anders formuliert zum Beispiel das Wort
Wehrhaftigkeit hätte ich wahrscheinlich
früher selber Sony in den Mund genommen
aber ja wir müssen als Europa für
unseren Frieden und unsere Freiheit
sorgen können und deswegen unterstützen
wir ja auch die Ukraine als europäischen
Partner in unserem gemeinsamen Europa
die Umsetzung dieser Strategie kostet
natürlich auch Geld insbesondere dass
erfüllen der nato-vorgabe zwei Prozent
der Wirtschaftsleistungen sollen ja in
die Verteidigung investiert werden ab
kommenden Jahr sogar das hat heute
Christian Lindner gesagt woher kommt
denn eigentlich das ganze Geld wenn das
Sondervermögen was er im Grunde auch
Schulden sind aufgebraucht ist
der Sondervermögen stellt erstmal dieses
Geld für jetzt bereit weil wir müssen
jetzt dringend neue Anschaffungen machen
nicht nur weil wir die Ukraine bei ihrem
Recht auf selbst Verteidigung und
Freiheit und Frieden unterstützen mit
bekanntermaßen zum Beispiel auch Panzern
die wir dann natürlich selber für uns
wieder neue modernisiert beschaffen
müssen sondern wir haben auch in den
letzten Jahren immer wieder erlebt gab
ja auch solche Schlagzeilen das
Hubschrauber nicht wirklich fliegen dass
das Material total veraltet ist und
deswegen müssen wir auch da wieder nicht
weil wir es wollen aber weil wir dazu
gezwungen sind mehr Geld in die Hand
nehmen für die Modernisierung der
Bundeswehr und hier aber das Gute im
Licht dieses Krieges haben wir erlebt
wie Unsinn ist ist um mich zu sagen
falsch dass alle europäischen Partner
sich selber ihre eigenen panzersysteme
oder
Abwehrsysteme beschaffen und die da
nicht miteinander funktionieren und das
ist bei uns in der nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie angelegt genauso
wie in dem überarbeiteten Konzept der
NATO und der EU das zukünftige
Beschaffung in Europa gemeinsam
kompatibel sein müssen das spart dann
für uns als gesamt Europa auch wieder
Geld damit wir nicht alles
aber Sie können ja nur sparen wenn sie
vorher auch irgendwo vielleicht schon
mal gehabt Geld locker gemacht haben
also noch mal die Frage woher kommt denn
das ganze Geld weil sie können nur
sparen wenn sie auch Geld haben
das stimmt und deswegen der
Sondervermögen hatten sie hier gerade
angesprochen das ist ein Teil der auf
Kredite finanziert wird und ein anderer
Teil wird aus dem Haushalt kommen das
ist eben leider auch die brutale
Realität das durch den russischen
Angriffs Krieg der russische Präsident
auch uns gezwungen hat in unserer eigene
Wehrhaftigkeit zu investieren stärker
als wir das bisher getan haben weil wir
darauf vertraut haben dass wir in Europa
gemeinsam immer in Frieden leben können
und das bedeutet jetzt zum Beispiel mit
Blick auf die Stärkung der Bundeswehr
dass wir bei diesem Haushalt deutlich
machen bei der Bundeswehr können wir
nicht kürzen sondern wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir die Ukraine weiterhin
militärisch unterstützen können und dass
wir selber für unsere eigene Sicherheit
als Bundesrepublik Deutschland in
unserem vereinten Europa sorgen können
sie wollten an anderen Stelle die
Verteidigungsausgaben koppeln und zwar
an die Entwicklungsausgaben das wird es
auch nicht geben warum nicht
zu Zeiten wo wir mit Russland den
Frieden gelebt haben mussten wir nicht
so intensiv in unserer eigene
Verteidigungsfähigkeit investieren
deswegen haben wir da deutlich gemacht
ist die Kooperation gerade im
Zusammenhalt der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit in dem
Diplomatie humanitäre Hilfe können wir
der mehr Geld leisten jetzt sagen wir
nicht wir kürzen hier aber wir machen
deutlich dass wir auch in unsere
Verteidigungsfähigkeit investieren
müssen und solche Abwehrsysteme das ist
jetzt ja allseits bekannte wie viel
Milliarden so eine moderne
Luftverteidigung kostet das sind eben
ganz andere Dimension da wir so viel
jetzt aber über Militär sprechen sie ja
die Fragen auch dazu stellen das
Besondere an dieser nationalen
Sicherheitsstrategie ist dass wir zum
ersten Mal sagen früher hat das
Verteidigungsministerium ist
Außenministerium eine
Sicherheitsstrategie geschrieben
Sicherheit ist mehr als Militär und
Diplomatie es geht ja auch um
cybersicherheit es geht hier um
gesundheitssicherheit um das
Lebensmittelsicherheit das haben wir
alle bei Corona erlebt wenn wir
Antibiotika in Deutschland jemand nicht
mehr von anderen Teilen der Welt
bekommen können bei uns ist aber nicht
hergestellt wird auch das ist ein
Sicherheitsproblem und das ist eben
dieser integrierte ganzheitliche Antwort
möglicherweise werden wir das ein oder
andere nicht mehr bekommen weil unser
Verhältnis zu China sagen wir mal
angespannt ist im Papier steht dazu das
Land versucht regelbasierte Ordnung
umzugestalten setzt seine
Wirtschaftsmacht im Grunde ein die
internationale Sicherheit damit auch
unter Druck ist also systemischer Rivale
bleibt aber Partner das ist alles sehr
abwägend und keine klare Haltung
also abwägend ist für mich nicht das
Gegenteil von klarer Haltung sondern es
beschreibt eben in einer Welt in dem wir
auf der einen Seite erleben dass
Autokratien Diktaturen auch in
systemwettbewerb also in den Gegensatz
zu Demokratien gehen dass wir da nicht
naiv sein dürfen das ist ja die bittere
Lehre aus unserer russland-beziehung in
der Vergangenheit da war das Prinzip
Hoffnung wir machen nur ganz viel
wirtschaftsbeziehung und dann werden wir
schon in Frieden leben das mussten wir
alle gemeinsam erst recht die Ukraine
bitter bezahlen diesen Fehler wollen wir
nicht noch mal machen und deswegen sagen
wir gegenüber China die sich in den
letzten Jahren auch massiv verändert
haben und eben diese beschrieben haben
unsere regelbasierte internationale
Ordnung nicht nur hinterfragen sondern
herausfordern machen wir deutlich wir
können uns nicht so abhängig machen wie
zuvor von Russland wir müssen uns
diversifizieren wir müssen uns breiter
aufstellen und zugleich so ist das in
einer globalisierten aber vor allen
Dingen meisten Welt wo CO2 nicht an
Grenzen Halt macht können wir die
Klimakrise nur in den Griff bekommen
wenn eins der größten Länder dieser Welt
nicht nur bevölkerungstechnisch sondern
auch mit einem starken Markt sich an
diesen Klima Vereinbarung beteiligt und
deswegen ja müssen wir alles dafür tun
dass wir mit China bei den Klimafragen
die Erderwärmung auf unter zwei Grad
möglichst 1,5 Grad bringen Annalena Borg
die Außenministerin war das federführend
für die internationale
Sicherheitsstrategie die heute
vorgestellt wurde vielen Dank danke
ebenso schönen Abend
und nächste Woche dann die
deutsch-chinesischen
Regierungskonsultationen dieses Gespräch
haben wir übrigens am frühen Abend
aufgezeichnet die Außenministerin hat es
gerade gesagt durch den Angriffskrieg
Russlands hat sich in der
Sicherheitsstrategie einiges verschoben
und dieser Krieg Gundula der fordert
auch heute wieder leider Opfer
wir sind bei russischen Raketenangriffen
in der Südukraine und im Donbass sie
willisten getötet worden mindestens
sechs Menschen verloren ihr Leben Moskau
behauptet stets nur militärische Ziele
zu beschießen getroffen werden aber
immer wieder Wohngegenden die Hafenstadt
Odessa wurde vom Schwarzen Meer aus mit
Marschflugkörpern angegriffen drei davon
konnten abgefangen werden aber Wohnungen
Geschäfte und Cafés sowie ein Lagerhaus
wurden beschädigt allein dort starben
drei Zivilisten
der russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine
die Not in Syrien die Gewalt in
Afghanistan und die Folgen des
Klimawandels treiben Menschen in die
Flucht mit weltweit 110 Millionen
geflüchteten hat die Zahl der
Betroffenen einen neuen Höchststand
erreicht und sich in den letzten zehn
Jahren verdoppelt der zuständige
un-hochkommissar grandi nannte es ein
Armutszeugnis für den Zustand unserer
Welt und immer wieder kommen Menschen
auf der Flucht ums Leben so wie in der
Nacht auf heute im Mittelmeer
südwestlich von Griechenland bislang
sind 79 Todesopfer bestätigt gerettet
wurden 104 Personen sie waren am
Unglücksort von einer Yacht aufgenommen
worden vermutlich waren gut 400 Menschen
an Bord des wohl überladenen Bootes
warum ist kenterte ist noch unklar
in Mailand haben tausende Abschied von
Silvio Berlusconi genommen auch viele
hochrangige Politiker erwiesen den
früheren Ministerpräsidenten die letzte
Ehre wie Ungarns Regierungschef Orban
für das Staatsbegräbnis rief die
Regierung erstmals eine eintägige
Staatstrauer aus Berlusconi war am
Montag im Alter von 86 Jahren gestorben
die Berliner Staatsanwaltschaft hat
Ermittlungen gegen Till Lindemann
eingeleitet den Frontmann der Band
Rammstein wegen des Vorwurfs möglicher
sexueller Übergriffe und der Abgabe von
Betäubungsmitteln gegenüber ZDF heute
bestätigte die Staatsanwaltschaft es
lägen mehrere Strafanzeigen vor dabei
handele es sich um Anzeigen Dritte die
nicht am Tat Geschehen beteiligt gewesen
sein Lindemann weiß die Vorwürfe zurück
seine Anwälte haben bereits rechtliche
Schritte angekündigt
aus Protest gegen die Gesundheitspolitik
blieben heute deutschlandweit Apotheken
geschlossen die Apotheker fordern eine
Erhöhung der seit Jahren fixen
Kostenpauschalen und weniger Bürokratie
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach hatte
Forderungen nach mehr Geld für Apotheken
bereits abgelehnt die Verbände machten
auch darauf aufmerksam dass die Zahl der
Apotheken seit Jahren abnimmt sie sehen
die flächendeckende Versorgung in
Gefahr
wenn Menschen in Deutschland sagen dass
wir hier in einer Diktatur leben dann
kann man darüber den Kopf schütteln
schmunzeln oder es einfach so stehen
lassen wenn aber ein Politiker dazu noch
ein stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
auf einer Demonstration fordert die
Menschen müssten sich die Demokratie
zurückholen dann ist das schon eine
etwas andere Situation die so wie jetzt
auch in Bayern Geschehen andere
Reaktionen nach sich ziehen über den
Fall Hubert Aiwanger die Kritik der CSU
die schnell verpuffte die Forderungen
der Grünen nach Entlassung des Chefs der
Freien Wähler und einen Antrag der
besonderen Art Alexander Pool
der Welt Uli Henkel ist afd-abgeordnete
aus München und eigentlich schon durch
mit seiner Rede da fällt ihm noch eine
Sache ein ich wollte den Herrn
Staatsminister jetzt einen
Aufnahmeantrag für neue Mitglieder bei
der AFD übergeben aber leider
gemeint ist Hubert eiwanger
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident und
Bayerns Wirtschaftsminister in seiner
Regierungserklärung heute kein Wort zu
seinem Auftritt bei einer Demonstration
gegen das sogenannte heizungsgesetz die
Opposition aber erinnert daran fordert
einwangers Entlassung
ihre Aussagen sind eine Schande für sie
und ihre Aussagen sind
eine für unser Land Samstag im
oberbayerischen Erding rund 13.000
Menschen versammeln sich darunter auch
afd-anhänger Querdenker Impfgegner eine
Demonstration gegen das heizungsgesetz
ein politisches Minenfeld Aiwanger
politisch ein Minensuchboot nutzt im
Landtagswahlkampf die Stimmung für eine
afd-reife Attacke gegen die
Bundesregierung
sagen ihr habt wohl den Arsch offen dort
oben meine Damen und Herren ein Tab
u wohl auch Markus Söder dabei war er
selbst nach Erding gekommen auch der
CSU-Chef setzt im walia auf eine
anti-ampelstimmung eine Stimmung die
seine Partei mit anheizt sie spricht vom
heizungsverbotsgesetz dass die Menschen
arm macht vom Heizungs
überwachungsgesetz in Erding nimmt man
ihm das nicht an anders als sein
Koalitionspartner eiwanger wird Söder
mit Berufen und pfiffen belegt ihm
bleibt nur die Flucht nach vorne
wer so agiert ist kein Demokrat für
unser Land von solchen Leuten grenzen
wir uns ab doch so das Grenzen scheinen
fließend die Frage wo und für was er
eigentlich steht schwer zu beantworten
vielleicht ist das Absicht der CSU-Chef
kämpft im Wahljahr nicht nur gegen die
Opposition sondern auch den eigenen
Koalitionspartnern Hubert Aiwanger der
Freie Wähler der unbeirrt Grenzen
überschreitet er kann Söder Stimmen
kosten im Wahljahr 2023 bleibt das
mitunter nicht ohne Folgen
wieder Schweinsbraten statt Insekten
oder maten Müsli und wenn ihr das wollt
Liebe grüne dann könnte das Zeug selber
fressen wir machen das nicht niemals die
Sprache die Markus Söder da benutzt ist
zumindest in Teilen ihm nicht die
Sprache die in der politischen Mitte in
Deutschland bislang üblich war es ist
eine Sprache die eher an die Zündel
Rhetorik der politischen Rechten
erinnert ohne dass es sich mit denen
gleich macht aber man senkt halt so das
diskursenniveau und so wird der
Wahlkampf in Bayern wohl lauter werden
als in den Jahren zuvor die CSU hat hohe
Erwartungen an Markus Söder und der
scheint fest entschlossen diese nicht zu
enttäuschen
können alles ist schlecht und wir
blicken jetzt mit dir Gundula auf die
Wirtschaft und da genau auf die
Finanzmärkte die schauen an diesem Abend
nach Washington wo die US-Notenbank vor
zwei Stunden eine neue Leitzins
Entscheidung verkündet hat in deren
Erwartungen war der DAX hierzulande
schon mal kurzfristig auf ein neues
Rekord hochgestiegen Frank Bethmann was
hat die fetten und gerade beschlossen na
dass sie jetzt einfach mal ein Päuschen
macht und was ich so beiläufig anhört
bringt in Wirklichkeit eine neue Dynamik
in die Zinspolitik ist das jetzt die
Wende nach der Wende wir alle erinnern
uns noch an den März des vergangenen
Jahres nicht zuletzt der Krieg in der
Ukraine löste einen Umdenken aus und
beendete eine Dekade historisch
niedriger Zinsen innerhalb von nur gut
einem Jahr erhöhte die US-Notenbank in
zehn aufeinanderfolgenden Schritten den
Leitzins von nahe null Prozent auf nun
mehr bis zu
5,25%. das alles um die Teuerung in den
USA wieder in den Griff zu bekommen was
den Link scheint und die Börse Jana hier
taten heute das was ihr am besten können
Sie spekulierten genau darauf die
Aussicht auf eine Zinspause in den USA
bescherte dem DAX heute im Verlauf ein
neues Allzeithoch von
16.336 Punkten und für morgen steht eine
Zinsentscheidung der EZB an was erwarten
die Experten da ja noch keine Pause die
EZB wird folgt man den Fachleuten morgen
den Leitzins um weitere 0,25% Punkte
anheben das sind Niveau in der Eurozone
lege dann bei
4,0%, das reicht sagen immer mehr
Unternehmer und Gewerkschafter fordern
auch hierzulanda eine Zinspause denn die
Wirtschaft befinde sich in einer sehr
schwierigen Phase die stark gestiegenen
Zinsen werden zu einer immer größeren
Belastung die am Ende auch viele Jobs
kosten könnte
man vielen Dank
eine weltweit erste und strenge
Regulierung für künstliche Intelligenz
hat das Europäische Parlament gefordert
und damit seine Position für
Verhandlungen mit der EU-Kommission
definiert demnach soll eine biometrische
massenüberwachung in öffentlichen Räumen
verboten werden dazu im heute journal
Update ein Interview mit dem
Europaparlamentarier Axel Voss von der
CDU
ARD und ZDF werden die Frauenfußball WM
in Australien und Neuseeland übertragen
alle 64 Spiele live im Fernsehen oder
online darauf haben sich beide Sender
und die FIFA jetzt geeinigt das
Eröffnungsspiel am 20 Juli in der ARD
die erste deutsche Partie gegen Marokko
am 24 im ZDF
das ist eine gute Nachricht die
Fußball-Frauen Weltmeisterschaft ist im
Freien empfangbaren Fernsehen und zumal
im öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen zu
sehen und wir werden das Ereignis was
eines der großen und wichtigen
Ereignisse in der Sportwelt in diesem
Jahr ist nicht nur live übertragen mit
allen Spielen sondern natürlich auch in
gewohnter Weise publizistisch begleiten
und wir haben hier jetzt die
gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch für
Sie sie lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 12
15 17 21
29 544 Superzahl 5 weitere Gewinnzahlen
auf Lotto zdf.de und im zdf-text auf
Seite 5 5 7
wer in diesem Jahr 18 geworden ist oder
noch wird kann sich seit heute in einer
App für den neuen Kulturpass
registrieren etwa 750.000 junge Leute
haben darauf Anspruch mit dem Kulturpass
bekommen die Jugendlichen ein Guthaben
von 200 Euro dass sie etwa für Konzerte
Museen Bücher oder fürs Kino einlösen
können so will die Bundesregierung
jungen Erwachsenen die Kulturszene
nahebringen und gleichzeitig Kultur
schaffende nach der corona-krise
unterstützen
die Beatles vor über 50 Jahren trennte
sich die Band zwei Bandmitglieder sind
mittlerweile tot aber die Faszination
ist bei vielen geblieben und bei manchen
vielleicht sogar erst vor Jahren
entstanden jedenfalls kommen Fans jung
oder alt nun in den Genuss gleich zweier
Neuigkeiten die erste Paul McCartney
will in diesem Jahr einen neuen Song der
Beatles vorstellen möglich wird sie
ahnen schon durch künstliche Intelligenz
die zweite die könnte nicht
gegensätzlicher sein Bildband
schwarz-weiß geschossen vom Bassisten
selbst zu sehen sind diese privaten
Einblicke der Band aus den 60ern Barbara
luke hat sich in die Augen des Sturms
begeben
februar 1964
während die Beatles im Flugzeug fiebern
und schlafen wölbt sich ein schwerer
Himmel über New York doch darunter bahnt
sich eines der größten kulturellen
Spektakel des 20 Jahrhunderts an
er kommt schon
als wir das erste Mal nach Amerika kam
nach New York als quasi Kinder die es in
England schon ziemlich geschafft hatten
als die Welt während der Tournee auf
diese vier Pilzköpfe blickt
greift einer selbst zur Kamera und Blick
zurück in die Welt
Paul McCartney fotografiert die gesamte
Tour er fotografiert was er sieht
hunderte Bilder die später in einem
Keller Archiv verschwinden
doch jetzt nach Jahrzehnten sind sie
wieder aufgetaucht in einem Buch
verewigt das heute weltweit erscheint
zum Schwelgen Schmökern schmachten
[Musik]
aber niemand hatte diesen Zugang den ich
hatte
[Musik]
diese Tournee
diese Welt was für ein Wahnsinn damals
die alte Ordnung erodiert
und die Leichtfüßigkeit der Beatles wird
zum Soundtrack einer Jugend die
plötzlich spürt dass sie die Welt
verändern kann
alle Dämme brechen
die Sixties sind da
es war das erste globale Massenphänomen
der Popkultur ihre Musik reiste um die
ganze Welt sie waren ein Mix aus vielen
Einflüssen sie selbst wurden extrem
cosmopolitisch
das vielleicht schönste Kapitel des
Buchs spielt in Miami zum ersten Mal
sehen die Jungs aus Liverpool Palmen es
sind fast zärtliche Zeugnisse jener Zeit
[Musik]
da waren Strand Sand und Mädchen ich
meine Kamera
nach drei Wochen Rückkehr in die Heimat
ihr Empfang stürmisch wie immer aber die
Welt ist ein bisschen anders geworden
wenn man schon irgendwie auch gerne
dabei gewesen aber kann man ja jetzt
durch den fotografischen Blick von Paul
McCartney ziemlich beeindruckt und ein
Muss für Fan
um 0:35 Uhr gibt es ja wieder unser
heute journal Update mit Nazan Göttingen
und wir sehen uns dann hier morgen
wieder wenn Sie wollen machen Sie es gut
wo auch immer sie sind tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend ein Höhentief heißt
Höhentief weil wir es in der
bodendruckkarte gar nicht sehen können
es mischt sich dennoch in unser Wetter
ein es bringt einige Wolken mit
Regenschauer und Gewitter und hält die
Temperaturen aufrecht tiefe Niveau das
ist schon ungewöhnlich aber noch
ungewöhnlicher sind derzeit die
Wassertemperaturen des Nordatlantiks die
sind zum Teil mehr als ein Grad höher
als üblich das Mittelmeer hat eine
Wassertemperatur von 22 bis 25°. es
könnte sich in unserem Wetter jetzt
demnächst was ändern und das liegt an
diesem Tief hier über dem Atlantik denn
ab Sonntag vielleicht Montag Dienstag
nächste Woche kann es dann von Südwesten
deutlich Schüler bei uns werden feuchter
und dann eben auch gewittriger nicht in
dieser Nacht da gibt's im Osten einige
Wolken im Westen ist es klar und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 14 bis 5 Grad
und morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
an der Ostsee und in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen bei 20 Grad sonst geht's
um die 25 Grad und dann wärmsten wird es
am Niederrhein mit 28 20 Grad auch
morgen gibt es viele quellw